foreign
comes from Sala in Colorado how do I
write a resignation letter I want to
keep it professional but companies need
to be called out on their so they could
do better in the future I love when Dave
steps in with the sound effect you can
just uh fill that in with your
imagination
um okay so let's just stick to the first
part of the question how do I write a
resignation letter I want to keep it
professional well then keep it
professional
um you know the the resignation letter
to me is is less important than the way
you handle yourself when you go in and
talk to your leader and uh you know the
advice I give to callers on the Ken
Coleman show as well as the Ramsey show
is leave the way you would want to be
left put yourself in the other person's
shoes even if it's not a great
environment even if you feel wronged or
whatever the reality is it never does
you any favors by burning the bridge or
blowing the bridge up which we're seeing
a lot of young people do on Tick Tock
for heaven's sakes just leave with class
it's gonna follow you when you least
expect it if you don't so on the
resignation letter I don't have three
points and here's how to do it it's very
simple be professional and keep it short
and sweet and you can turn it in when
you look at your leader thank you for
the opportunity please accept my two
week notice that's it keep it simple
gratitude Clarity let me just tell you
say like if if they cared
what you thought about them
they would have already asked you
they don't care yeah for whatever reason
because they're Dom or because you're
belligerent I don't know which right but
they don't care what you think
so you telling them to get their
blankety blank blank stuff in order is
going to do zero good that's correct
because they don't care what you think
period that's right okay I I you know I
probably fall in that category well I
think most everyone if you're if I you
know I quit doing exit interviews now
our HR team does exit interviews because
they want to try to find out why you're
leaving I'm not leaving
I'll be here yeah so I don't you know I
see you I I love you but I'm gonna keep
going you're not yeah and that's pretty
well the end of it that's right and you
know I don't need you throwing grenades
back in here at me as you leave it does
it does nothing except Make Me Remember
You that way that's right and the
probability or the percentage chance of
you telling them what you think about
what they need to change oh I never
thought of that I'm so glad you told me
I'm so thankful it's never gonna happen
so just just just leave yeah leave well
keep it simple and you've stayed too
long
if you feel that way if you're willing
to say companies need to be called out
on their blank that is absolutely you've
stayed too long yeah you needed to you
need to either call them out on their
blank and stay and help fix their blank
um you know or you're part of the
problem now and you've become part of
the problem so yeah you do need to get
out of there just keep it brief sweet
and say see ya wouldn't want to be you
and move on you know and
um then you can smile later when you
calm down and you're gonna go well they
probably weren't as stupid as I thought
they were and so on you know yeah you
know it always cracks me up Dave when
people want to take a parting shot at
somebody and if it's so bad that you
want to leave then why aren't you happy
you're leaving you should be bubbly you
should walk in and go hey I'm leaving
today you know it's like what are we
doing the problem is social media has
raised a whole generation of activists
and everybody thinks they're a freaking
activist right you're not an activist
you're just a former employee
there's a difference I mean seriously
that's just your category you're just a
former employee that's all you are and
nobody really gives a crap what you
think they really don't that's correct
you and the three people that sit around
drink coffee with you and whine about
stuff from four years ago you're the
only ones that care you know and that's
so some of you people do this stuff and
and uh we've had it happen to us here
we've had it happen you know I've Got
Friends that run companies and and
people that do stuff and you know
they've never erected a statue to a
Critic that's true just never been done
so except that one to Roger E Roger
Ebert but um anyway Cisco neighbor
remember that yeah oh sure actually has
a statue oh he does I thought you were
kidding no that's I actually said that
from stage one time there's a famous
saying uh like Mark Twain or somebody
said he's never been a statue that's
correct somebody sent me a of course
they did a picture of Robert Roger
Ebert's statue good for him yeah that's
good well I mean you got to have
something to do